Your money's not here.
It's on the blockchain.
It's in Joe's transaction and Mrs. Macklin’s
transaction.
It's a digital currency.
Run down to the market and buy the biggest
turkey in all of London!
Then take it to Bob Cratchit's house.
Do it fast and there's half a crown it for
you.
Well is that it?
I'm sorry?
That's your contribution to society, huh?
Half a crown and a turkey?
I also donate to charity!
Oh, great charity!
Where you get to decide
where your money goes!
Yes.
Wow.
Yes, after I pay federal and state and local
taxes;
the remaining money, I dictate where it goes
to.
That is so like the One Percent! it's people
like you who are
destroying America!
Or Britain... or wherever the hell we are.
Do you donate money to charity, sir?
I raise awareness on Facebook.
That doesn't sound like a real thing.
It's a real thing!
Why don't you do that and volunteer at a soup
kitchen ?
I don't have time to volunteer because I'm
raising
awareness on Facebook!
And when the shepherd saw the light in the
sky, they
rejoiced with exceeding great joy, for the
Space X Falcon 9 rocket had successfully launched
the satellite into orbit and returned autonomously
to their platform.
No no, I want an official Red Rider carbine
action 200 shot range model air rifle!
Sure, kid.
We need these tariffs.
Our trade deficit with the North Pole has
never been bigger.
Santa is killing us on trade.
He's killing us.
There's a trade deficit between me and the
grocery store
that doesn't mean I need to have more taxes
on me buying groceries.
Oh, hi.
[Off screen] Who is it?
It's carol singers.
[Music plays: Silent Night]
...and paste him in a manger because there
was no room at the inn,
for the City Council had banned Airbnb as
anti-competitive.
All these people are talking about Santa's
naughty list and
his nice list,
but it's his kill list that should concern
us!
[Music plays: Silent Night]
You've got a foreigner violating DC airspace
and you're telling me we don't need a wall?
Listen kiddo, you're getting older and it's
time we had a talk.
There's no such thing as Sanders.
The man
is real, but the policies are just fantasy.
It's something that we made up so that kids
and college sophomores would have something
to get excited about.
You selfish undemocratic prick!
I don't understand what you want from me!
You have too much stuff!
Give us your stuff!
The system which incentivizes me to
accumulate stuff also incentivizes me
to create wealth for you.
Oh, well then, why are there poor people?
Abject poverty is the natural state of man.
The question isn't why there are poor people,
it's why there are rich people.
Just give me your stuff!
No!
Gahh, I am so going to picket this house.
Huhaha!
Good luck going to a
restaurant, buddy.
We're going to be there.